[Music]
let's be honest the majority of students
don't really enjoy going back to school
you're not alone we found cartoon
characters that share exactly how you're
feeling stick until the end to see which
characters dislike school the most hey
guys check out our new member of the
family toy hub toy hub is the ultimate
place for kids to get their daily dose
of crunchy slime squishy slime sticky
slime play-doh color learning and so
much more
we have lots of fun with the most
awesome toys and amazing stories for
kids make sure to show it to all the
kids in your family and while you're
there make sure to subscribe and hit
that like button at toy hub it's
playtime don't forget to give this video
a big thumbs up and subscribe sharpen
your pencils because today we're
checking out ten cartoons that perfectly
sum up back to school SpongeBob
SquarePants
who lives in the pineapple under the sea
SpongeBob SquarePants
you know we have to mention one of our
favorite characters whose school antics
seemed to perfectly sum up exactly what
everyone feels when they think about
going back to school
although spongebob seems to love school
the school doesn't seem to love him he
is constantly getting in trouble and he
definitely gives us
back-to-school filled on the other hand
spongebob also shows us what it's like
to be an adult with his to-do list one
of our favorite school scenes from
Sponge Bob is the time he draws a
perfect circle but in a true spongebob
fashion he seems to be drawing it
backwards the internet turned it into a
hilarious meme
speaking of Spongebob Squarepants here
are some facts for you so you can get an
a on the next spongebob trivia quiz did
you know that Patrick and Gary the snail
are actually first cousins their
relation was confirmed by Patrick's
family tree which quite frankly is just
super confusing there's another one for
you mr. Krabs was born in 1942 you can
find his details on his driving license
and probably one of the most important
spongebob facts is that Stephen
Hillenburg the creator of the show is
actually a marine biologist he first
created a comic book for his young
students to help them envision what
happens under the sea and a lot of the
scenes acted as a basis for the show if
you need a cartoon to cheer you up
before you head back to school
spongebob is a good choice South Park
when it comes to a back-to-school mood
South Park is to show you absolutely
have to watch South Park has a way to
pretty much capture all of our moods but
seeing those characters in school is
something every one of us can relate to
one of our favorite school themes from
South Park is when Cartman runs for
student body president
and then learns it's a position without
any power Cartman has raged against the
school several times and there are
plenty of more moments where we were
able to identify with exactly what are
you feeling he's really not holding back
is let us know your favorite part in the
moment in the comments here's some South
Park trivia for you
Kyle's out of control hair was actually
modeled by the co-creator of the show
Matt stone do you remember Terrance and
Phillips we always wondered why their
characters look so simple and here is an
explanation they were a direct response
to those who criticized the show for
being nothing other than bad animation
the show really knows how to stick it to
the man and get away with it doesn't it
they even hold a Guinness record for
most swearing in an animated series
South Park can definitely identify with
your back to school moon gravity falls
gravity falls is definitely a must watch
before you head back to school the story
of a fictional town where mystery seems
to lie around every corner is
captivating but it's the quirky and
relatable characters that really make
this show what it is if there's a
character you'll be able to relate to
it's definitely Wendy although she's
fairly laid back Wendy absolutely
dislikes high school and in one of our
favorite scenes
she told Mable High School is not what
it looks like on TV we've all wished for
our school to burst out in song like
High School Musical but the truth is
that just doesn't happen and Wendy knows
it this scene with Stan
also perfectly sums up two types of
students as much as we'd love to be the
stand on the web we're probably the
stand on the right Alex Hirsch the
director of gravity falls
save some very interesting trivia
answers after season one gravity falls
was supposed to go on an eight-month
hiatus but Alex managed to negotiate it
down to just four months Mabel's awesome
sweaters are actually based on Alex's
twin sisters sweaters Alex also said he
was surprised the fans of the show liked
Pacifica and she was meant to be
portrayed as a [ __ ]
character a lot of the characters are
actually based on real-life people we
but everyone would like to have a
character like Wendy in their school the
Powerpuff Girls sugar and spice and
everything nice let's talk about some
old school Cartoon Network shows
Powerpuff Girls were a Connick and are
definitely a beloved series to this day
the story follows three little girls
that were created in a lab they all got
super powers but they also lead normal
lives like going this school in this
scene the girls pretty much sum up the
best part about being in school hands up
if you love lunch and here they are
looking pretty much like we all look
after the first day of being back in
school it looks like it's really hard
being a superhero in school remember
this scene where they get reminded that
they need to ask for permission before
they can leave to save the world they
seem to have a love-hate relationship
with their teacher in 2016 Powerpuff
Girls got a reboot directed by Bob Boyle
the new show expands on the girls
maladies and if you haven't seen it yet
it's definitely a must watch before you
head back to school did you know that
Elizabeth Daly who plays the original
Buttercup appeared on the US version of
the voice the cast of the Powerpuff
Girls can definitely tell you all about
following your dreams and sticking it
out through school Hey Arnold speaking
of old-school classics there's nothing
like watching
hey Arnold right before you head back to
school Arnold's face perfectly sums up
what most of us feel like when we're
stuck in a boring class and we're just
counting down the minutes for the bell
to ring it looks like all students in
hey Arnold
feel the same about school you can't
really blame them and if you're not
Arnold we bet you can relate to Helga
and her self-love if you're a hey arnold
fan here's some trivia for you that you
might not know this show was ahead of
its time when it was on the air it
featured LGBTQ characters and it
probably had one of the most racially
diverse cast ever and it all started
when short clips of the show first aired
during Sesame Street's the animations
look completely different from the show
you know today
hey Arnold is also the first show that
actually used kid voice actors even
Powerpuff Girls ever crossed that line
speaking of Arnold do you know his last
name was never actually revealed on the
show the secret came out in 2016 by the
creator himself
Arnold's last name is shortened the show
is definitely worth to be watched before
you head back to school
Teen Titans go our Channel mentioned
Teen Titans goes several times and we're
definitely
fans of the show there hey you don't
forget about me in your memory episodes
can definitely relate to all fans as
Robin tries to convince the rest of the
group to go back to school Robin bribes
them by saying he'll buy the new clothes
and of course it once they're all
excited and Starfire even talks about it
being the beginning of a meaningful life
experience but then Robin put the label
on everyone's the job in this case
cyborg can't hang out with Beast Boy and
so on so on it's the classic
representation of what actually happens
in school and the scene really does
perfectly sum up a student's experience
the cast of Teen Titans go described the
show as apples to oranges when compared
to the original Teen Titans they all
agree that the show is fun and it's nice
to have quirky superheroes that were
made for children when it comes to the
show the cast also admitted they
improvised Paul watts which is exactly
why we're able to identify ourselves so
much with the characters they're all
just crazy like most of us are we do
recommend watching the episode that
talks about labels and social norms as a
reminder that you don't have to stick to
the status quo The Simpsons
speaking of old-school who can forget
about the record-breaking show that
remains one of the most popular cartoons
out there The Simpsons is absolutely
honey and no matter how old you are
you're able to identify with the show
and enjoy its storyline we particularly
love how Bart experiences school and
we're pretty sure his hands perfectly
sum up some of your school news from his
messages on the blackboard during
detention to him being absolutely bored
during class Bart really sums up how
most of us feel about being back to
school speaking of the Simpsons did you
know that the characters are yellow just
because they grab the attention of
people who are just flicking through the
TV channels they definitely managed to
grab their attention Conan O'Brien wrote
for a couple of The Simpsons episodes
like Marge vs. the monorail before he
became a talk-show host another
interesting fact is that Bart's voice
actually belongs to Nancy Cartwright who
also voices nelson and ralph we do hope
that none of you had to write as many
sentences as Bart did during his
detention there are many chalkboard gags
out there but our favorite is my but
does not deserve a website where your
detentions harsher than Bart's ed ed and
Eddy
speaking of old school it doesn't get
any better than re watching ed ed and
Eddy before you re-enter the school
world this Cartoon Network classic is
just so silly and witty it'll lighten up
your spirits the show definitely
highlights some back-to-school moods
that just really sum up the experience
in a nutshell from school bus rides and
classroom boredom all the way to not
enjoying PE
and Evan Eddy highlight just about every
move you'll end up experiencing at
school ed ed and Eddy is such an
interesting show it has way more fan
theories than it does have fat
notice that all of their tongues are
actually blue there's a theory floating
around that Edie Edie and Eddie aren't
actually alive the fans also wonder
what's actually underneath
Ed's hat since it's never really
revealed some are guessing he's bald but
many suspect that his haircut is
actually so bad it's best that it's not
revealed and did you know that the
creator of the show also worked on a
couple of other series for hanna-barbera
a studio that's responsible for iconic
shows like scooby-doo the Flintstones
and the Jetsons no wonder Edie Edie and
Eddie was so successful but we do have
to ask one question when do these kids
actually go to school The Fairly
OddParents one of our favorite shows on
this list is without a doubt the fairly
oddparents
the show is so popular it even managed
to crossover with the very last cartoon
on our list we absolutely love following
the adventures of timmy turner and his
fairy godparents the show features some
of the most quirky characters out there
but what we loved the most was seeing
those characters in school this picture
of Timmy in a classroom pretty much sums
up most of our moods when we think about
going back to school he's really not
having it is he we all also know at
least one person in our class who always
brags about their age if you know that
the show was originally called the fairy
godparents
Wanda's name was Venus and she looked
totally different from the Wanda we know
and mr. Crocker the elementary school
teacher was inspired by Eugene Levy's
role in the movie flaps but did you know
that he wasn't originally meant to be on
this show and was created for another
cartoon imagine the show without mr.
Crocker we bet you have a few crazy
teachers like that in your school
but we hope they're not as mean of mr.
Crocker the loud house when it comes to
favorite shows you can't deny that the
loud house stole the limelight of all
modern cartoons
we've previously shown you what the loud
house characters would look like in
different situations but what we also
love is whenever these characters are in
school this scene with unimpressed LuAnn
is pretty much all of us as is the face
Lennie mix while on her way to school so
early in the marine we definitely
recommend the loud house as the crap -
you are back to school speaking of the
show did you know that the characters
were originally supposed to be rabbits
this is why some of them featured buck
teeth and why Lincoln is the only one
with white hair were so glad they became
humans so we're able to see their
interactions in school all of the loud
house characters are also based on the
creator's actual large family which
consists of ten children his sister's
names actually made it on the show and
some characters are even named after
their dogs
we can thank Nickelodeon's Jenna Boyd
for pulling Chris Savino aside after
their meeting and telling him to turn
the characters human we can't wait to
see what the characters will do in
future episodes and we definitely expect
more back to school moon
and that's it for ten cartoons that
perfectly sum up back to school make
sure you check out videos like ten
innocent cartoons fans in other
countries see you in the next video
[Music]